only fans model courtney coleny charged
with murder we are charging 26 year old
courtney taylor clenny with one count of
second-degree murder
in christian's death christian is
christian toby obumsilli courtney's
boyfriend whom she stabbed to death back
in april fast forward to this wednesday
and u.s marshals arrested the social
media star in hawaii on a charge of
second-degree murder with a deadly
weapon the reason why she was in hawaii
her attorney says is because she has
been receiving ptsd treatment and
related issues to this case christian
whom courtney dated for two years was
found dead inside a luxury condo in
florida when authorities arrived at the
scene of the attack this past april they
discovered courtney in the unit with him
devastation doesn't quite describe what
my family is experiencing right now the
model's arrest warrant states there had
been multiple incidents of domestic
violence from both sides during the
relationship evidence gathered during
the investigation
of christian's death
showed that since november of 2020
he
and the defendant
clenny had been involved in an extremely
tempestuous and combative relationship
at the time of christian's death
courtney's lawyer insisted she was
acting in self-defense
he's not welcome to stay he was not on
the lease
but he did make his way
back up to the apartment on several
occasions during that week
but miami state attorney catherine
fernandez rundle says the police didn't
find any evidence that she had been
harmed by christian the police observed
no visible injuries
which would have corroborated her
account
and she had no injuries courtney is set
to be extradited to florida from hawaii
she has not yet been brought to court
for a hearing
but when she does go for a hearing
she will at that time
have the option to either wave or
contest extradition
it is our understanding that her lawyers
have stated that she will waive
extradition
you